here comes a guy right here who's trying
to be like me
[Laughter]
boys been seeing a little bit too much
of that uh
purple turtle or that brown cow
oh but it's time for the blue eagle baby
salute got a bait club for you here
either that river
it seems flipping or that cold waterfall
dipping
this guy's sexual huh that seems
nice this looks like a herbal essence
commercial
gang gang
buzz buzz he didn't know what to say
but he covered it pretty well yeah he
did usps doug
shout out to usps man you know the
workers they're good people man they get
people out there hustling get in the
mail doing this and doing that
you know when i was growing up they had
a fella and he would bring the mailbus
and he would do all the uh
he would open all of the perfume samples
and smell them all bro he had some
condition or something you know yeah so
you get your perfume samples and they'd
already been smelled you know
remember how they used to have their
perfume samples yeah every now and then
you get a little freaking hit of noir or
something i'd save it for the dance when
i had a school dance hell yeah
i put that [ __ ] under my little uh no
one to use it son i had like this metal
like thing you put your clothes on i'd
slide it under there and then
when it was time for the dance i'd get
that thing out you know
but he kept using them all so they'd
come and be like oh damn this dude
smells great but
i smell like [ __ ] this dude's harboring
all the good smell that's
trying to come through the neighborhood
through the u.s postal system but i'll
say this man there's no shittier system
going on in america right now than the
u.s postal system
hey dog why set him up just to bring him
down
i love the workers because of because
the voting [ __ ]
no no he's a great this guy's a great
guy man and i wish him long prosperity
we don't know him but yeah you know and
i love y'all's movie too what's the one
with kevin costner
you got me postman postman
um and but i'm telling you the truth
brother
yeah and that is that
oh [ __ ] man what's going on are they
[ __ ] up or something no not at all
what can brown do for you [ __ ]
they i mean look you mail something on a
tuesday bruh it gets there
next year dog you know you don't know
when something's getting there
true they'll send them a letter says hey
your letter's coming
but they but they won't even get the
letter dog i'm just saying it's become
a shoddily reliable system
and that's why amazon took out that's
why i mean the u.s post system could be
amazon man
nah not really they don't have the
infrastructure but they could have over
all of this time they're just screwing
around and they're violent
you get into the regular place they
violently say hey here's my mail card
see if my mail is coming to lady league
going vacation
you be violent too if you always worry
about dogs and [ __ ] they they're doing
the lord's worst man
pit bulls chasing them rottweilers okay
we're just trying to drop off your
shitty porno magazines just download it
you gotta get it the physical i feel
like the paper though
i like old school feeling and i can't
even download it anymore i have too many
blockers on my
on my electronics did you block your
calculator too
huh oh yeah that calculator deleted that
yeah okay
um it's tough man oh but his
his uh king you're stinging it was uh
waterfalls or jumping in that
cold river or yeah yeah rivers
rivers or waterfalls it was a cool video
who cares about his topic right yeah
they're both good dog i like to go down
that river lazy boys
when i was young these people was more
wild though remember there was a time
when people were sh
at the postal place were shooting up the
office remember that yeah
it seemed like every other day for a
little bit there and suddenly
you know all the heavy hitters brought
all the bad boys out of the usps
they are either locked up or they're
gone or they join antifa
yeah you got this guy more of a hippie
kind of relaxation nature
you know nature male boy you know i miss
those old school bad boys dude you know
what i'm saying dude come in with a
stamp you know a book of stamps
and a and a book and the book of mormon
bro you know
look at stamps and book of mormon yeah
book of eli yeah a book of samson a book
of eli
thank you nick and i'm going to repeat
your joke
[Laughter]
that's how we do it on here yeah you
would roll in with just uh uh
you know i'm i'll miss the old guys with
the weapon if that guy would have
flashed a weapon in the vehicle
i'm in wait wait can any of you guys
flip into the water
i can flip it in the water yeah yeah
yeah you theo
no front flipping i can i can if i want
to
and i want to go back and say this too
to the postal man
hate on him yeah be easy man my best
friend his his family is all postal i
love
look dude you keep saying that and then
you [ __ ] on it
you don't love him you have a deep
hatred for him obviously he doesn't like
their operation
i am he likes the people i get my
[ __ ] mail all the time what's wrong
with you dog your problem is you bounce
around all the goddamn time
well the problem in one spot a lot of it
is is i also want to say it's
los angeles based mail you send a mail
they don't get it
you go over to the mailbox in the park
and the guys you know two homeless dudes
have been using it to raise bees in it
you know and there's nothing they can do
the city can't touch it they're like oh
we gotta let them do it
we gotta wait till the bees leave
naturally before we can use it for mail
again i'm not worried about the [ __ ]
mail someone keeps taking my uh ups and
amazon packages though
that's what you gotta worry about you
order some nice [ __ ] and somebody's
stealing your package
they just busted a guy he'd been he
worked for uh amazon and he was just
taking all this up to his house
yeah i got these stupid [ __ ] on video
even mm-hmm and
the cops came over like there's not much
we can do yep
really yep ring cam i got him get a uh
bow and arrows yep i'll shoot that
[ __ ] right in the butt dog
get a bow and arrows dude hit somebody
in that femur yep what's this
kid talking about you could you could
just order a bunch of packages for a
couple days wait out there that'd be fun
shoot them yeah or you could buy the s
um what is it the confetti gun that like
when you open it up after they try to
steal a package it explodes everywhere
yeah yeah if you were a clown yeah
i don't know where
ups worker in a supreme hat let me know
man
that's my [ __ ] so he's obviously
filipino
yeah man dude i'm just saying bro
i respect the male people i used to go
sleep over my buddy jeff saviac's house
they had a [ __ ] gas leak over there
his dad did the mail
and we would put all kind of stuff in
his mailbag we would open mail
you know we'd be over there
y'all haters doing a shout out to all
the grandmothers who sent those two
dollar bills
today grandsons man we had
bank around then dude i was buying runs
candy every
day i'd be rolling up with those two
dollar
bills dude and it'd be like oh yeah i'd
even sometimes i would open it instead
of having a wallet i just have one of
the christmas cards and i'll just have
all the money in it
stacked in there damn we were living
large man it was a good times bro
gas leaks in the u.s postal
[Music]
it's the king of system games